So today I thought we'd take a little bit
of a deeper look at Joe Biden's 2020 platform.
And I don't just want to read through his
positions.
What I want to do is pick a few areas and
think about whether Joe Biden's ideas, whether
Joe Biden's policy positions, his policy prescriptions,
his platform.
Would Joe Biden's policy ideas really deal
with root problems or would they fix symptoms
of a problem?
And I want to make a couple of things clear.
Number one, we have a system that incentivizes
dealing with symptoms and not problems when
you're in Congress.
You have a reelection every two years and
you have to justify being reelected.
Presidents have four year terms, senators
six.
But of course, it's much more difficult to
get big things done sometimes in the Senate,
depending on what type of thing you're talking
about.
Although that doesn't always apply.
So we fundamentally have a system that encourages
not really dealing with the systemic problems
which often take more than two or four years
to deal with, but rather dealing with symptoms
or even appearing to deal with symptoms without
actually dealing with them.
So we're going to talk about that now.
A few important things to think about.
One is I'm going to go by Joe Biden stated
2020 platform.
Now there are going to be people who write
to me and say, I don't believe that Joe Biden
actually wants to do X or Y, even though he
claims he does listen to some extent.
No president does what they promise.
And every candidate states that they will
try to do things that are very difficult to
do or almost impossible to do.
Look at Donald Trump's presidency for an example.
But this is a pointless exercise.
If we're simply going to say, oh, here's Joe's
list of stuff he wants to do.
I think he's just lying.
OK.
I mean, listen, that that's it's impossible
to defeat that argument if you want to insist
on making it number two.
Some of you might say, well, why aren't you
talking about Biden wanting to cut Social
Security?
Again, I'm going by Biden's 2020 platform
in the 90s, Joe Biden said he would consider
putting Social Security cuts on the table
if a proposal otherwise made sense to him.
It was 25 years ago.
It's not part of his platform today.
There's no real reason to include that in
his platform because it's simply not.
Lastly, when I talk about solving a problem
versus dealing with the symptom, let's use
an example from the Trump presidency.
Trump believes the solution to undocumented
immigration is to build a wall across the
entire u.s.-mexico border.
Building a wall at best deals with a symptom.
Right.
The wall would potentially slow down the portion
of people coming to the U.S. illegally by
physically crossing the u.s.-mexico land border.
That's a symptom of the problem to solve the
actual problem.
You would have to deal with, number one, the
economic conditions in Latin America that
lead people to want to come to the United
States illegally in the first place.
You would have to deal with more strictly
punishing or punishing at all companies that
hire undocumented immigrants, because as long
as companies keep doing that and not being
punished, they're going to continue doing
it.
And number three, you would also have to account
for the higher prices that would come on many
products if indeed you rooted out all undocumented
labor in the United States.
So building the wall may be addressed as part
of one symptom, but it does nothing to deal
with the problem.
That's the type of thinking that we want to
do here.
I'm not going to do all of Joe Biden's positions,
but let's do some of the key things.
We'll start with criminal justice on criminal
justice.
Joe Biden wants to eliminate mandatory minimum
sentences, eliminate private prisons and the
cocaine sentencing disparity, end the cash
bail system and eliminate the death penalty.
So to answer whether this deals with the problem
or just symptoms, you have to understand what
the problem is.
I would generalize the problem with our justice
system, including the courts and criminal
justice system, as we have a two tiered system,
one for the rich and one for the poor with
a heavily racialized component and a for profit
component that has no business being there.
And it is at its core, a system that is focusing
too much on street crime and not enough on
corporate and white collar crime.
So when I look at what Joe Biden wants to
do on criminal justice, I would say that this
is somewhere in the middle between fixing
symptoms and dealing with the problem.
Biden goes directly at some elements of the
problem.
So ending cash bail in private prisons that
deals with the for profit component of the
problem.
But the problem is way bigger.
And this proposal from Joe Biden does nothing
about setting priorities in terms of street
crime versus corporate and white collar crime.
Doesn't address that at all.
Biden also is not in favor of legalization
of cannabis.
That is a massive criminal justice issue.
And he is not in favor of it.
So I would say that Biden on criminal justice,
he's just past dealing with only symptoms
towards getting at some of the problems, but
it doesn't do nearly enough.
Now, by the way, this is Trump's a disaster.
So this is not a comparison with Trump.
I want to make that really clear.
Next, let's look at the economy.
Joe Biden on the economy.
OK.
What is Joe Biden's economic policy?
Joe Biden wants a $15 an hour minimum wage.
He wants paid family and sick leave, a 1.3
trillion dollar infrastructure package.
Roll back the Trump tax cuts, meaning raise
the top rate from thirty seven to thirty nine
point six percent.
Extend the payroll tax to $400000.
Currently, that caps out at about one hundred
thirty eight thousand, raise the corporate
tax rate from 21 to 28 percent, tax capital
gains and dividends as ordinary income after
$1 million a year.
And then put a 15 percent minimum tax on large
companies to prevent them from using loopholes
and deductions to end up paying zero.
So here Biden starts to get at some of the
actual economic problems in this country inequality,
a system designed to allow you to pay less
and less as a percentage of what you earn
as you have more and more.
This applies to rich individuals and corporations
as well.
So Biden is getting at some of the fundamental
problems here.
Now, what Biden doesn't deal with in terms
of problems are the absolutely sky high costs
of living in much of the country, 15 bucks
an hour.
It's great, but it's not a living wage in
much of the country.
Doesn't deal with guaranteeing a living wage,
doesn't deal with the loopholes that are disproportionately
used by the super rich.
So, for example, taking the payroll tax threshold
up to 400000 this year, it's one hundred and
thirty seven thousand seven hundred that hits
people earning between one hundred and thirty
seven K and four hundred K.
But then it goes away and we can have a debate
over what's right and what's fair and what's
economically sensible.
But the point is, if you're above 400000 a
year in income, you're unaffected by that.
And the ultra rich who are really benefiting
from a lot of the loopholes and mechanisms
that exist, they're earning way more than
$400000 a year.
Another example, the top tax bracket would
go back to thirty nine point six percent under
Joe Biden.
That's what it was before Donald Trump.
OK, great.
But that doesn't go nearly high enough.
And we need we need higher and more tax brackets.
We probably need.
There's a bunch of proposals, but we probably
need like a 42 percent tax bracket at a million
and then we would go to a 48 percent.
OK.
So we need more brackets and they need to
go higher.
Biden does a little bit, but he's not really
dealing with it at at a more core issue, which
is the ultra ultra rich that as a percentage
of their total income are actually paying
lower rates.
But there is some good stuff in there and
night and day compared to Trump.
I mean, truly night and day.
In short, Biden's economic policy platform
is a completely predictable, uncontroversial,
moderately left proposal.
It deals with symptoms.
It gets some problems, but it doesn't do nearly
enough.
It's way better than Trump.
Let's do one more area for today, which is
health care.
This is obviously huge.
Biden on health care.
He has said that he supports lowering the
Medicare age from 65 to 60, would create a
public option, would give free access to the
public option.
If you're in a state that didn't do the Medicaid
expansion that was part of Obamacare, there
are Republican governors who said, OK, Obamacare
includes this Medicaid expansion, but we're
not going to do it.
If you are in one of those states, you would
get free access to the public option even
if your state didn't do the expansion based
on income, up to 138 percent of the federal
poverty level.
That's like five million people.
And then Biden would also increase tax credits
by eliminating the 400 percent poverty level
cap and limiting the total out-of-pocket cost
to 8.5 percent of income.
That would be down from close to 10 percent.
And the credits would be based on gold plans
rather than I don't remember if it's bronze
or silver currently.
That raises the amount of the credits.
And then Biden would limit launch prices and
price increases on drugs as well as allow
foreign drug purchases.
So there's a lot there.
It is not Medicare for all.
It is not universal.
There is no doubt about it.
What is the numbers that that this would achieve
if you lower the Medicare age from 65 to 60?
I believe it adds 18 million people to Medicare.
I don't have that number in front of me and
I had a little trouble finding it.
But going from memory, I believe it's about
18 or 20 million more people that would get
Medicare by lowering.
The age from 65 to 60.
It's not universal, but a lot of people up
free public option in states without Medicaid
expansion would add again about 5 million,
4.9 million people.
And then there are certainly millions more
that would be able to afford health insurance.
With this, is it a panacea?
Of course not.
Is it better than Trump's proposal with Republicans,
which would have seen 24 to 32 million more
people lose insurance?
Of course it's better than that.
The symptoms are.
Care is too expensive.
It's sometimes low quality and it's not accessible
to everyone, in large part because of the
for profit system that we have.
Does Biden's plan change the problem of health
care being for profit?
Of course not.
He doesn't believe that's the problem.
That's a major disagreement right now, even
within the Democratic Party.
Biden deals substantively with symptoms.
And the way he does it is you get care to
more people and you make it affordable for
more people.
But not everyone.
So let's step back a little bit.
To sum up, we have a system that encourages
at a fundamental level because of the frequency
of elections, how politics is financed, needing
to raise money, etc. and how long things take
to get done.
We have a system that incentivizes appearing
to deal with symptoms.
Sometimes you're actually dealing with a symptom.
Sometimes you're only appearing to and optics.
Very much are the only thing that actually
matters when Congress is up for reelection
every two years.
When presidents get four year terms, we have
to understand the difficulty in a system like
that of dealing with problems.
This doesn't excuse candidates or presidents
who don't do it, and it doesn't encourage
only dealing with symptoms.
We just have to understand that reality.
Trump, by and large, has identified the wrong
symptoms and is dealing with them in a completely
farcical way.
That's how I would sum it up.
Joe Biden would actually deal with these symptoms
in a way that would function reasonably well,
but would only start to get at the underlying
problems.
That's my assessment on health care, economy
and criminal justice.
We could look at environment and others and
maybe we will do so.
Let me know what you think about this framework
of symptoms vs. problems.
I'm on Twitter
at David Pakman.
We'll take
a quick break and so much on today's program.